i would really like a milkshake all our  flavors are listed on the board behind  me small writing i can't  you just tell me what what flavors you  have there  he reluctantly reveals his eyesight is  fine oh  don't read very well  would you mind going through them for me  how do you not know how to read this  couple looks stunned by her questions  okay sorry i'll help you out  they have almond amaretto banana  butterscotch caramel caramel pecan  chocolate turns out that for them this  situation is personal  that can't breed and it's legit okay  that's very rude i'm just asking a  simple question  your manager will know about that  i'm just asking a simple question  that can't read i understand well i mean  how does that even happen it's called  people having to go through a tough life  sometime